[Musique]
pendant les 16 jours des vacances à 16
heures une nouvelle vidéo est postée sur
le compte facebook de la bergerie qui
présente un des acteurs de
l'exploitation agricole qu'il soit
animateurs ou dans la production qui se
présentent entre une minute et 2 et 2
minutes et dans le décor qui lui est
dédié on y trouve on retrouve le petit
lapin voyageurs de catcheur l'idée t2c
cette vidéo c'est de vraiment mettre en
avant le projet de l'exploitation qui
est un projet orienté sur une
agriculture très respectueuse de
l'animal le bien-être animal et de
l'environnement puisque ça s'appelle
l'agroécologie donc chaque voilà on a
orienté les vidéos pour que chaque
personne finalement va parler d'un d'un
élément un des collègues va plutôt
parler du bien-être animal de un autre
sur l'autonomie alimentaire quelqu'un
d'autre sur les circuits courts
les témoignages sont déjà sympathique de
voir qu'ils sont contents de voir qu'on
que finalement la vie continue à la
bergerie malgré tout finalement les gens
sont et saïd est là le plus possible en
direct mais on est beaucoup beaucoup
suivi plus tôt après finalement les gens
peuvent retrouver les vidéos les
facebook live ensuite et c'est vraiment
le point fort finalement de cette
méthode virtuel c'est de finalement de
pouvoir toucher des gens qu'on touche
serait peut-être pas et qui profitent de
des vidéos ludiques et éducatives encore
longtemps après